begin this morning with dangerous
weather threatening about half of the
nation
heavy rain and powerful winds of
tropical storm claudette are bearing
down
on the already storm weary central gulf
coast
the system is about 45 miles south
southwest of new orleans moving north at
about 12 miles per hour
maximum sustained winds are 45 miles per
hour
police responded to high water rescues
throughout the night in slidell
louisiana just north of new orleans
the region could receive 5 to 10 inches
of rain
with as much as 15 inches in some places
omar villafranca begins our coverage in
biloxi on mississippi's gulf coast omar
good morning
good morning tropical storm claudette
formed at about 4 00 a.m
came ashore and started pounding this
area with heavy rain we're in biloxi
here right by the casinos which are very
popular
right by a marina you can see all these
shrimp boats behind me
they've had to obviously dock up and
wait but now that it's past air just
waiting
to get back out there and get back to
work now here in biloxi
when that heavy rain came ashore the big
concern
was going to be flash flooding in the
area we saw several cars stuck in water
and low-lying areas
the winds were also whipping around here
pretty good 50 mile per hour gusts
were reported in the area there were
also some sort some tornado warnings
overnight there's also some
tornado warnings right now just east of
us and gulf shores
as we speak over in slidell as you
mentioned they got close to 10
inches of rain over there that caused
flooding problems cars stuck in the
water
as well officers had their rescue
equipment ready
just in case now this system is now
moving farther east
as we speak so the folks that are in the
florida panhandle in alabama they're
getting ready
for what blew through here but folks
here are ready to get back to work and
to
possibly have a weekend jeff omar thank
you very much to the